[Music]
most people think that owning a parrot
is
a walk in the park but the truth is
they're very very complex creatures in
every way
they're long-lived they can be noisy
they can be destructive they have
special needs
they challenge you can you say brock
like a dog for me please
people buy them sometimes for the wrong
reasons or they buy on impulse
and
when there's a problem they call me
[Music]
my name is glenn cerrino and i've been
working with birds professionally for 20
years
new york city has always been my
backyard
i had parakeets growing up as a kid and
i was fascinated
everything about them appealed to me
eventually i started to
research
parrots read everything i could get my
hands on
spoke to other bird owners went to bird
club meetings and even took a job at a
bird store that opened up a lot of doors
for me
people started calling me
glenn
i'm having a problem
can you help me
i thought i had a male parrot but after
20 years i just laid an egg hello
you name it and
the call started coming in people
started flocking to me i can use that
term
one thing led to another and eventually
i became the go-to guy and it developed
into a business
on a day-to-day basis i provide a
variety of services
i'm there whenever they need me
basically 24 7.
every day is something new every day is
a challenge
each bird has a different behavior
they're like people they have likes
dislikes they have special needs in the
way of diet
lighting environment the larger species
can live a human lifespan
owning a bird is literally like having a
five-year-old child that never grows up
if you can imagine that bird owners
often have problems with aggression
health issues plucking
egg laying issues mimicking sounds that
become
incessant
[Music]
i have one client who was feeding her
bird waffles with maple syrup and pasta
with vodka sauce
so we had to change your diet and we had
to change it fast
every situation presents a challenge
my role is to
try to help them through all of that
if you understand how a bird thinks if
you understand what a bird is telling
you and the way the pupils dilate the
way they fan their tails
you can figure out what they're trying
to tell you
i can tell if they're being cautious at
first and i approach them very gently
again i speak their language and i don't
think there's anyone else who really
does what i do you're looking really
good thank you
okay
okay
frankie you want to come out i believe
that i i do have a unique role in the
bird world
i feel the the work that i do is very
rewarding to me
i love birds i
help clients solve problems and when
they call me up and tell me that
everything is great that i really help
them it makes me feel like i'm really
making a difference in the world
and and i love a happy ending and
nothing makes me feel better than
knowing that i did a good deed
[Music]